in the forecast fragment we want to
modify the fetchweather task so that we
can pass in the postal code parameter
when we execute that task
you can click on this class to jump to
where it's defined or you can use this
shortcut
and here you see that we modified the
generic input type to be a string
so that the do and background method
receives string params
now we only passed in one string param
94043 so when you see down here later we
can read out the 0th position in the
params array to get that postal code
notice that we're using the uri builder
here and we're appending query
parameters one by one we define
constants for these query params as seen
here
and for the values we also define them
up here
you can imagine that in the future these
might be configured outside of this
class but for now we're just going to
define them here
to verify that this uri was built up
properly we add a verbose log command to
print out the built uri
let's verify that the log we added
actually shows up
in the overflow menu we tap refresh
then we see the log tag fetch weather
task with our uri printed out it says
json format metric units seven days so
this looks correct